bang bang like I'm telling them top
wearing an oversized fur coat Louboutin
heels Dior Shades and her trademarked
long nails cardi was granted a second
chance by the New York Court I feel like
I've been in a lot of drama last year
she was ordered to complete 15 days of
community service after pleading guilty
in a 2018 assault at a strip club the 30
year old rapper now has until March 1st
to complete her sentence as for Todd
Chrisley he and wife Julie are on day
two of their combined 19-year sentence
for bank fraud and tax evasion and they
won out we spoke with their lawyer Alex
little today is the fight to get out
already started absolutely they know
they have an opportunity to appeal their
case that's what they're doing we have
the struggles that everyone else has and
we work through them as a family
thedailymail.com captured Todd hiding
his face with a pillow in his final
minutes of Freedom entering this
Pensacola Florida Federal facility it
allows for five adults not including
children to visit at any one time but
will daughter Savannah even go but I can
say that my daughters no walk in the
parking
yesterday the 25 year old posted this
pic of her mom captioned will forever
fight for this smile I love you Mama
fans noticed she didn't do the same for
her dad just the hateful comments on
social media and people just having no
Grace or understanding well you are
allowed to visit with family and again
this is a close family and they're
obviously going to spend time visiting
with one another the reality stars will
file their appeal ahead of the deadline
which is February 22nd this trial was
riddled with heirs and we expect the
appeals court to see that we've heard
Todd talk about making a documentary
what do you think could be in a
documentary that might ultimately
vindicate them I think there's two
things I mean I think the very beginning
of this case was an unconstitutional
search by the Georgia Department of
Revenue the second piece is one of the
IRS officers who testified about whether
the Chrisleys had paid certain taxes
that certainly we think affected the
jury and we believe it'll be a basis for
a new trial
thank you
[Music]